the flood waters may now be receding
but at its peak it caused chaos the
roads surrounding
building aquadrome holiday park in
northamptonshire became rivers
in a matter of minutes leaving hundreds
of people
stranded this estate is home to 500
caravans
and every single one had to be evacuated
among them peter who was forced to sleep
in his car i run my own business i'm
quite a successful
person and having watched the news
looking at the people's plight in dover
i never once anticipated
that i may be without a home on
christmas eve
this year and so this for sure is a
christmas to
remember but for the wrong reasons
fire and rescue crews worked late into
the night
when your living room is submerged in
flood water staying at home
isn't an option for 22 hours one was
separated from his dog churchill
who was trapped inside their caravan i
wasn't on site he was
i came back to find that i couldn't get
in um
and last night there was a lot of
firemen and
emergency services who were dealing with
it um
but i still was not allowed to get my
dog they said they would go and
sort that for me which um this morning
um
i had nerd anything so i managed to get
in a hole in the fence
northamptonshire is far from the only
place affected
in newport pagnol many woke up to a wet
christmas
rising waters left residents in a
desperate place to protect their homes
it's devastating it's not exactly been
the best year
um and it's just another thing to add to
um
2020 of things that are not
good yeah across the country the
environment
agency has issued more than 100 flood
warnings
this street is unrecognizable the water
here has made its way from a river
catchment
causing flooding and the situation may
get even worse
with more bad weather expected in the
hours ahead
the arrival of storm bellow and boxing
day will cause further downpours
and the authorities are warning those
living in areas at risk
to be vigilant meanwhile in east
yorkshire northeast england
and suffolk snow has brought some
festive smiles
but for those affected by the floods
this is a christmas they'd rather not
remember
noel phillips sky news in
northamptonshire